you can always be better customers have
a divine discontent and they teach you
if you listen to customers
when i'm 80 now 90 i have i want to have
minimized the number of regrets
that i have in my life you have to
always be leaning into the future
if you're if you're leaning away from
the future the future is going to win
every time
need motivation what's your top 10 with
believe nation
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
jeff bezos and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one minimize regrets
when i'm 80 now 90 i have
i want to have minimized the number of
regrets
that i have in my life and most of our
regrets are acts of omission
they're things we didn't try it's the
path untraveled
those are the things that haunt us rule
number two think
long term what do you say to employees
when
you have obviously have some traders in
the stock who are not happy and suddenly
the stock is down 25
after a quarter well i so
for well since 1997 at
almost every all hands meeting we have
two all hands meetings a year
at almost every all hands meeting i
remind employees
that you know if the stock is up 10 this
month don't feel 10
smarter because when the stock is down
10 some month you're going to have to
fill 10 percent dumber and it's not
going to feel as good
and so it's you know ownership is
uh we give most of our compensation uh
is is done in terms of uh stock
compensation
and uh and part and parcel with
ownership is a mentality of of long-term
thinking you know you
owners think longer term than renters do
so i have a friend who rented his house
to some tenants and
instead of getting a christmas tree
stand at christmas they just nailed the
christmas tree into the hardwood floors
of the house no owner would ever do that
and um but sometimes that's a bad tenant
you know they're a good
good tenants but that's a bad tenant and
it's because you know this is the same
old thing about you know nobody ever
washed a rental car and um
you you take better care of the things
that you own and and
uh but but one of the responsibilities
of ownership
and definitely deep inside the amazon
culture
is to think about the fundamentals of
the business and not the daily
fluctuations in the stock price
there's no information in it rule number
three listen to your customers
you shop on amazon yeah and uh
if you have something the service you
don't like yeah so do you just pick up
the phone
call your team of 700 000 people and
tell them i don't like this change this
or
you know what i do so um i don't do this
it doesn't happen that often but if i
get a
delivery that i don't like maybe i don't
like was packaged or something we have
regular
meetings of the senior executive team
and i bring the box
to the meeting and when i walk in i
haven't done this in a while it's been a
while but when i
bring in a box everybody in the room is
like oh no he's bringing in a box
because it's always some problem but
really the way i get
feedback is to is primarily from
my email address is very well known and
i keep it well known
and i get hundreds and hundreds of
emails every day from customers
and they always have something
interesting to say when something goes
wrong
because we have hundreds of millions of
customers around the world and no matter
how good we are
we can still be better you can always be
better
customers have a divine discontent and
they teach you if you listen to
customers
so we watch for that and we see patterns
and we can find places where it's not
working
something's going wrong and that's
really how i get the feedback is from
customer
input and often you know in all caps
angry you ruined my child's birthday
because the gift didn't show up on time
and we take that and what you really
want to do
is you take that it's an anecdote it's a
single example
but you need to find the root cause what
went wrong
deep inside the system how did this
happen because then you can fix it for
everyone
so that particular problem will never
happen again you don't just fix the
symptom you have to fix the root cause
and that's been the secret to our
operational success for 20 years
rule number four empower others what i
want to achieve with blue origin
is to build the heavy lifting
infrastructure that allows for
the kind of dynamic entrepreneurial
explosion of thousands of companies in
space
that i have witnessed over the last 21
years on the internet
so when i think about the founding of
amazon.com
it it only could work so it will take
you back
to 1995 july 1995 we open our doors
and this is a 10 person company i'm
driving the packages to the post office
myself
and we had we were sitting on a bunch of
heavy lifting infrastructure
otherwise a tiny company could never
have started amazon.com you couldn't do
it
for example there was already a gigantic
logistics network
called the us postal service and ups and
fedex
that would have been tens of billions
actually hundreds of billions of dollars
of capital that you would have had to
have laid out if you had to
build a logistics network we didn't have
to do that it existed that heavy lifting
was already done
um the the the internet itself
was sitting on top of at that time
the long distance phone network again
tens of billions
hundreds of billions of dollars of
capital put in place for long distance
phone calls
but repurposed for the internet payment
system
there was already a payment system we
didn't have to do that it was called the
credit card and it had been initially
put in place for travelers
and so on and so on and you can go
through and what we were able to do
is take all of that heavy lifting
inference infrastructure
and kind of reassemble it in a new way
and
do something new and inventive with it
and that's
one lens through which you can view the
founding of amazon.com
in space today that is impossible on the
internet today you know
two kids in their dorm room can reinvent
an industry
that's how how uh because
you don't the heavy lifting
infrastructure is in place
for that today two kids in their dorm
room can't do anything interesting
in space you know you could build a
cubesat there's not that much
interesting about cubesats
and the um it'll be that may change but
right now there's just
you need there are certain laws of
physics and certain things you need
size for and things need to be big we
need to be able to put big things in
space
at low cost and so if i'm 80 years old
and i can say to myself
that blue origin did the heavy lifting
you know i'm using my amazon winnings to
do a new piece of heavy lifting
infrastructure
um uh which is low-cost
access to space vehicles have to be
reusable you can't throw them away
throw away space vehicles every time
you're never going to lower the cost
so we're trying to lower the price of
admission into space
so that thousands of entrepreneurs can
then do amazing surprising things nobody
in 1995 that much predicted
snapchat you know it's like i can't
predict for you
what amazing entrepreneurs brilliant
amazing entrepreneurs will do
in space but i know if i give them
low-cost
access to space some brilliant
you know 22 year old is going to figure
it out it's one of those things about
what companies get sustainable it's
those that provide
platforms upon which others can build if
you amazon
empower others empower others to do
things
so aws is like that kindle direct
publishing is like that
our third-party selling business is like
that fulfillment by amazon is like that
every time you figure out some way of
providing tools and services that
empower
other people to deploy their creativity
you're really on to something
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self confidence i've
created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below if
everything has to work in two to three
years
then that limits what you can do the
stress primarily comes
from not taking action for me i've seen
small things get big and it's part of
this day one mentality
i like treating things as if if they're
small rule number five
build a strong company culture my
opinion
is that i can do some things that amazon
that would be hard for other people to
do only because of my history with the
company
and my as the company has grown of
course
my job has changed very much and um
it has my main job today is i'm kind of
the
i i i work hard at helping to maintain
the culture
um you know a culture of high standards
of operational excellence
of uh you know of inventiveness of
willingness to fail uh willingness to
make bold experiments
i'm the i'm i'm you know i'm the guy i'm
the counterbalance to the institutional
know who can say yes
but i won't you know i'm not going to be
here forever amazon is a really
the many of the traits that make amazon
unusual are now deeply ingrained in the
culture in fact if i wanted to change
them i couldn't if i decided
tomorrow that i wish amazon did less
pioneering
and more close following i couldn't do
it
the culture is um is
you know cultures are self-reinforcing
and that's a good thing
um you know the the the people who come
to the company
we get sometimes people come to the
company and they can't they're
they find amazon very boring because we
don't have enough you know competitive
zeal
you know we don't wake up some annual
planning processes and so and some
companies literally start with who are
our three biggest enemies
and then you know here's how we're going
to hold them at bay or defeat them
and we don't have such a list at amazon
it's not how our annual planning process
works and so but if you're on the other
hand if you're the kind of person who
gets up in the morning and says
in the shower time you know what can we
invent for customers and what can we do
differently and
how can we improve that experience and
so on and so on then you know then it's
going to be a playground
is there i still run into work by the
way i took my family on vacation
to uh france my wife's extended family
there were about 20 of us
and we had an unbelievably good time
great food everything were there for a
week i got back to seattle and i ran
into the office i'm having so much fun
rule number six lean into the future as
number one
on the list we're talking to steve case
yesterday and he had been number one
and a couple of years later he was not
on the list
well you're making me really nervous no
no don't be nervous just tell me
what could happen that would do that to
you and amazon
and how do you prevent that do you worry
it could all come unraveled
well i kind of have this experience kind
of already happened to me because
you put me on the cover of time magazine
his personal year in 1999
and about a year later the internet
bubble burst i think
amazon's stock went from 113 dollars a
share to six or something like that
so these things happen the thing for
companies is you need to be um
nimble and robust so you need to be able
to take a punch
uh and you also need to be quick and and
and innovative and
and doing new things at a high speed
that's that's the best defense against
the future
and you have to always be leaning into
the future if you're
if you're leaning away from the future
the future is going to win
every time never ever ever lean away
from the future
rule number seven experiment to be
innovative
you have to experiment if you want
to have more invention you need to do
more experiments
per week per month per year per decade
it's that simple you cannot invent
without experimenting and here's the
other thing about experiments
lots of them fail if you know it's going
to work in advance
it is not an experiment
and what happens in big organizations
that amazon's a big organization now too
the air force is a big organization
is that we start to confuse
experimentation
with operational excellence so
we you know operational excellence is
one of our four key principles at amazon
we're building a fulfillment center
we've built over 150 large fulfillment
centers around the world now
we know how to do that that is not an
experiment
if we build the 151st fulfillment center
and screw it up that's just
a failure that's not the kind of failure
we're seeking
we want failures where we're trying to
do something new untested never proven
that's a real experiment and they come
in all scale sizes
rule number eight focus on customer
obsession
there's your completely massive and
globally dominant commerce business
first party and third party there is aws
amazon web services which came out of
nowhere and is now massive
you're in the hardware business
including echo and kindle and and the
phone
grocery delivery payments tv
shows you're now making tv shows
advertising
jeff how can you possibly do all of that
exhausting me
how can you possibly do all of that and
do it okay
even okay let alone good so
i think one way to think about this is
what are you really focusing on
so um you know i'm focusing
on those things that i think make amazon
unusual
uh genuine customer obsession
so like every single thing you just
mentioned when
you know when our senior executives sit
down and review those
programs they're looking for customer
obsession
rule number nine diversify the question
was
um why uh why did we expand into things
like electronics tools and kitchen
since those businesses are not today
profitable
um and the answer is that um
that it increases our addressable market
size so
we can ultimately build a much larger
company by entering into those new
product categories
and and second while it's true that
those
new categories which are only three
years old and by the way electronics
tools and kitchen is now
a 600 million dollar business at
amazon.com which makes it
one of the largest on and it's on a
standalone basis it's probably in the
top four
or five e-commerce companies anywhere in
the world
so that business is growing and growing
very rapidly and has it one of the big
advantages
has a huge audience of early adopters
which is why companies like segway
choose us as the exclusive launch
platform for products like that because
really early adopters are the kind of
people who buy stuff like this
so it's uh uh but that business
ultimately will be electronics in
particular in my opinion will be our
largest most profitable business one day
when you start a new business there are
certain fixed costs that come along with
starting that business and then the
business
has to reach enough scale so that the
profit from the business the variable
profit
can cover those fixed costs there's no
sidestepping that and it's just a simple
investment uh issue
and rule number 10 the last one before
very special bonus clip
is have fun
straight back
hmm
and this is really do you want me to
solve that rubik's cube
yeah no thank you i can't even do that
with my hand
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway
from this video and what is your
specific plan of
action for the next week when you just
watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35 chance of
following through
but when you get motivated and then
create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 chance of
following through
that's what we do here believe nation we
get motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances even further of following
through
so what was your biggest takeaway from
this video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you the best advice i can give somebody
is do something that you think is
interesting
and let the waves catch you you know
something that i see people do which i
don't think is a is a good idea
is they try to chase the current thing i
saw this so much in
1997 and 1998 1999
with respect to the internet there were
you know in 94 and 95
96 97 mostly
the people who were you know the kind of
the earlier you get the more true this
is but
you know the people who were sort of
looking at this space and starting
companies were genuinely interested in
it they thought it was really cool
um by the time you got to 1999
like doctors were stopping you know
screw that doctor thing
i'm going to start a dot-com company you
know and so
um that really made no sense whatsoever
you know people were sort of abandoning
the things they were genuinely
interested in trying to catch a wave and
whenever you try to catch a wave you're
almost always too late
so it's it's better to just i mean if
you're paddling after it you basically
have to wait in place and let it come to
you
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there